[Musique]
dans mon métier je suis souvent prise à
partie parfois au point de mai vapore
avez vous déjà entendu parler de
dramathérapie si vous en avez déjà
entendu parler vous derrière vos écrans
c'est que vous êtes une espèce en voie
d'apparition la drama thérapie c'est un
nouveau chemin à explorer new passe tout
explose la drama thérapie c'est une
approche non médicamenteuses
contrairement aux médecines parallèles
ou alternatives dont l'effet n'est pas
démontrée sur la santé la haute autorité
de la santé française a publié un
rapport d'orientation en 2011 dans
lequel elle fait état de trois
catégories les règles hygiéno
diététiques
les thérapies physiques comme la
kinésithérapie et les thérapies
psychologiques comme les art thérapie
les art thérapie c'est une grande
famille dans laquelle il y à là danse
thérapie
les art thérapie arts plastiques arts
visuels la musicothérapie et la drama
thérapie
les art thérapie se pratique dans
beaucoup de contextes différents dans
les hôpitaux psychiatriques en oncologie
en pédiatrie dans les centres médico
psychologiques en ehpad ans dans le
milieu carcéral dans des écoles dans des
réussite éducative des foyers de vie en
libéral et d'autres lieux encore donc la
drama thérapie c'est la rencontre des
arts de la scène et de la thérapie pour
me former
j'ai d'abord été formé en tant que
comédienne conteuse marionnettiste dans
différentes écoles à l'université puis
en tant que thérapeute avec un master à
l'université paris 5
j'aimerais être très clair sur un point
il n'y a pas de thérapie son thérapeute
l'art n'est pas thérapeutique en lui
même
dans une psychothérapie classique c'est
la parole qui est au centre du processus
en drama thérapie on utilise les outils
des arts de la scène entre le patient et
le thérapeute il y a le jeu l'écriture
l'improvisation le théâtre la
marionnette le conte le masque du clown
et d'autres encore je sens des visages
inquiets ou dubitatif derrière les
écrans
mais n'ayez pas peur je vais vous
expliquer tout ça avec des avec des
exemples concrets dans quelques instants
donc pourquoi est-ce que la drama
thérapie est un nouveau chemin à
explorer pourquoi est-ce que c'est un
chemin vers une meilleure connaissance
de soi même parce que c'est une pratique
corporelle en utilisant sans de la
psyché et le corps et puis parce que
c'est une pratique qui propose un détour
par la fiction c'est à dire qu en va du
réel à l'imaginaire au symbolique pour
revenir ensuite au réel allez je vais
vous ouvrir les portes de mon cabinet
pour vous présenter quelques études de
cas j'aimerais tout d'abord vous parlez
de muriel noël c'est une jeune fille qui
est venue me voir quand elle avait 13
ans elle était en feu au bus scolaire et
en publie sociale elle avait subi du
harcèlement dans le collège dans lequel
elle était elle n'arrivait plus à sortir
de chez elle les premières séances ont
été très difficiles
elle communiquait très peu elle avait un
peu peur de moi et puis un jour je lui
ai proposé des marionnettes
je les ai mises devant elle je vous ai
dit de choisir celles qu'elle souhaitait
elle a pris un grand loup et puis je lui
ai proposé de choisir une marionnette
pour moi elle a choisi celle d'une
petite fille elle a augmenté sa
marionnette de loup et puis j'ai
augmenté la mienne deux petites filles
bonjour toi qu'est ce que tu fais là tu
vas où
moi je suis le loup et j'ai faim et là
je me suis évaporée on a recommencé
et puis systématiquement tous mes
personnages étaient engloutis par seul
ou alors je propose est autre chose
bonjour je voudrais juste passer mon
chemin
d'accord et là j'ai pu passer mon chemin
et on a pu commencer à jouer ensemble et
puis de l'imaginaire on est retourné au
réel on a pu parler à partir de cette
scène qu'est ce qui s'était passé
qu'est ce qui la dérange et pourquoi est
ce qu'elle me manger à chaque fois il a
pu mettre des mots sur ce qui était
difficile pour elle sur ce qu'elle avait
vécu avant ça a été ma porte d'entrée
pour un dialogue avec elle on a continué
à travailler
et comme elle a pu pratiquer dans un
milieu où elle était en sécurité et
protéger aussi par la marionnette
petit à petit elle a appris à mieux se
connaître et a posé ses limites et
aujourd'hui elle a trouvé un équilibre
je voudrais vous parler maintenant de
martine martin c'est une femme de 50 ans
je pense que vous connaissez tous
quelqu'un qui ressemble à martin
derrière sa demande initiale
j'ai vite compris que ce qui était
compliqué pour elle c'était de dire non
elle acceptait de faire des heures
supplémentaires avec son patron elle
acceptait tout ce que son mari lui
demandait elle se plier en quatre pour
ses enfants
et voilà martine là elle était épuisée
et l'on pouvait plus elle comprenait pas
pourquoi on a commencé à faire des jeux
de rôle les jeux de rôle
ce sont des jeux théâtre rouge donne un
personnage et puis j'en prends un autre
j'ai pris le personnage d'un agent
immobilier plutôt vers eux elle devait
donner le personnage d'un client qui
vient visiter ambiante pour le louer
bonjour j'espère que vous m'avez amenée
tout le dossier aux fiches de paie
depuis les deux dernières années
vos avis d'imposition et puis vos
factures aussi j'aime pas les mauvais
payeurs
bah oui vous m'avez amenée aussi les
3000 euros en petites coupures biais de
50 d'ailleurs c'est ce que je vous avais
bien demander non que j'ai oublié mon
carnet de reçus mais c'est entre nous
vous me faites confiance
1 oui et puis vous avez vu l'état de
l'appartement là vous allez repeindre un
ce que ça ressemble un peu à un taudis
là ça serait bien que ce soit un peu
mieux non ben oui bien sûr là j'ai
repris ma voix ma voix de thérapeutes
enfin martin vous avez vu je suis au
dieu vous pouvez pas me répondre oui
c'est inacceptable comme situation
vous êtes d'accord alors dites moi non
on recommence essayez de le dire même
tout doucement
alors c'est 3000 euros vous les avez
amené vous avez pensé à repasser les
billets comme je vous l'avais dit j'aime
bien les billets bien plat bien rangée
que ça fasse des beaux petits paquets un
nom petit à petit venons mais sorti et
il s'est fait de plus en plus audible on
en a refait des scènes on en a fait
beaucoup se seraient pas débloqués comme
ça en une séance
mais un jour elle est venue avec sa
victoire elle avait dit non la veille à
son patron elle était rentrée chez elle
à l'heure à l'heure de son contrat alors
qu'ils étaient corrects elle était très
fière aujourd'hui martin réussit mieux à
mettre ses limites est resté une femme
très douce très attentionné mais elle
trouve son chemin pour se sentir bien à
sa place
j'aimerais vous parler de paul et
stéphanie
paul et stéphanie je les ai accueillis
pour un conte de naissance le compte de
naissance est un protocole que j'ai créé
où les familles viennent me raconter la
naissance d'un enfant une essence
potentiellement traumatique et j'en fais
un récit paul avait des problèmes à
l'école
à 5 ans son institutrice se plaignaient
de ces comportements violents à
répétition autant envers ses camarades
quand vers l'institutrice elle même
stéphanie la mère de paul se plaignait
aussi de la violence de son enfant à la
maison j'ai rencontré l'abord stéphanie
tout seul pour qu'elle m'explique
elle m'a raconté que pendant toute sa
grossesse
le père de paul son compagnon de
l'époque la battait elle avait espéré
qu'à la naissance de l'enfant tous calme
qu'il devienne une famille harmonieuse
heureuse mais ce ne fut pas le cas
les coureurs prirent très rapidement
alors courageusement stéphanie est parti
avec paul s'installer ailleurs
elle n'avait jamais raconter son
histoire et son enfant et maintenant
elle souhaitait le faire
c'est donc ce qu'elle a fait pendant les
premières séances
paul écoutaient attentivement tout en
dessinant il était plutôt calme loin de
l'enfant qu'on avait décrit et puis est
venu le moment pour moi d'écrire le
récit
alors j'ai demandé à paul quel
personnage il souhaitait pour qu'on
puisse en faire une fiction
c'était son choix il m'a dit que pour sa
mère il souhaitait une part de pizza
j'avais jamais entendu ça et vous pouvez
bien imaginer derrière la part de pizza
la passivité
c'est tellement pour son père une
abeille une abeille bourdonnante
menaçante
et puis pour lui même un rhinocéros bien
fort bien solide
j'ai donc écrit l'histoire
il était une fois magnifique part de
pizza au fromage fondant et en même
temps coustilles hantent cette part de
pizza tomba amoureuse d'une abeille qui
traversaient le ciel
elle ne fut pas inquiété par ces
bourdonnements qui pourtant était
lancinant ensemble il conte sur un petit
rhinocéros fort courageux bien ancré sur
ses pattes
paul et coutal racing le sourire aux
lèvres cellules et bien tous ces
personnages on sait que le travail
autour du traumatisme
quand on utilise le récit permet
l'intégration de ce traumatisme
paul ça l'a apaisé elle a été plus
paisible à l'école et puis ensuite plus
paisible à la maison ça aussi ouvert un
dialogue entre la mère et le fils qui
n'avait pas encore eu lieu
qui va sans doute continuer j'aimerais
enfin vous parlez d'un appel à la belle
c'est une jeune fille de saison c'est sa
mère qui m'a contacté parce qu'un label
avait deux visages que c'était compliqué
à gérer un visage à la maison avec
décolère pas possible et une intolérance
totale à la frustration
et puis un visage à l'extérieur
extrêmement timide et renfermé à la
belle avait très peu d'amis et pas
d'activité elle est juste à l'école avec
annabelle j'ai utilisé l'improvisation
thérapeutique
c'est un jeu dans lequel les personnages
peuvent se transformer la situation peut
bouger je jouais un peintre elle était
mon modèle
oui c'est ça lève la jambe
voilà comme ça les met tous un petit peu
en arrière encore voilà encore en
arrière et lève le bras de mon temps
vers le ciel oui
ouvrez plus grands les yeux c'est très
bien et cartes les doigts de pieds voilà
à ses très jolies
oui continué à reculer par contre un il
faut pencher encore un peu et c'était
tellement inconfortable mais elle
continue elle faisait tout ce que je lui
demandais alors j'ai décidé de jouer un
modèle avec
je suis allée la rejoindre et t'en a pas
marre là de ce peintre
bah oui moi aussi qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
le jeter par la fenêtre à tous bon
d'accord on y va ok de 3o voilà
qu'annabelle avait exprimé des émotions
qu'elle avait pu exprimer son ras-le-bol
qu'on lui dise tout le temps ce qu'elle
devait faire dans un lieu où on joue
c'est un lieu où on est en sécurité
ce qu'on peut s'exprimer librement y
aura pas de conséquences c'est ce qu'on
a pu faire avec le jeu rejouer rejouer
rejouer des scènes où elle pouvait petit
à petit
apprendre à s'exprimer sans être en
danger sans avoir peur et c'est comme ça
qu'il ya un équilibre qui a pu se faire
entre l'intérieur et l'extérieur
elle a pu exprimer des choses plus
complexes à la maison et puis aussi à
l'école avec ses camarades et
aujourd'hui elle est beaucoup plus
apaisé platon disait on connaît plus
d'une personne en une heure de jeu quand
une année de conversation alors bien sûr
comme je voulais dit plus tôt c'est pas
magique en une heure que je transforme
les gens que je les aide à mieux se
connaître à aller mieux
ça prend du temps il faut de la
répétition mais ça marche je vais vous
donner quelques petites idées pour
activer votre créativité tout en étant
bien clair sur le fait que je ne vais
pas vous donner des exercices
thérapeutiques
puisqu'il n'ya pas de thérapie sans
thérapeute vous pouvez par exemple le
tenir un journal
et puis dans ce journal il faire des
exercices créatif
pourquoi pas y ajouter des dessins de ce
que vous ressentez des peintures des
collages y mettre des photos
et puis pourquoi pas faire des exercices
d'écriture avec des contraintes par
exemple vous pouvez écrire une lettre à
l'enfant que vous étiez vous avez
peut-être des questions à l'enfant que
vous étiez
et puis vous pouvez écrire la réponse de
cet enfant qu'est ce qui vous dirait
aujourd'hui si vous regardez ou alors
une lettre à un ami perdu de vue depuis
longtemps
qu'est ce que vous voulez lui dire sur
votre vie aujourd'hui
ou encore une lettre à vos émotions une
lettre à votre colère une lettre à votre
tristesse une lettre à votre joie la
drama thérapie n'est pas reconnu en
france aujourd'hui on a beau avoir des
diplômes des masters et des doctorats
on a beau travailler dans beaucoup
d'institutions le titre n'est pas
protégé pourtant il est dans beaucoup de
pays aux etats-unis au canada en
angleterre en roumanie aux pays-bas en
lettonie dans d'autres encore j'ai bon
espoir qu'à force de travailler et de
montrer que nos méthodes fonctionnent
notre métier soient protégés autant pour
moi que pour vous braque disait l'art
est une blessure qui se termine en
lumière merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]